when you're
falling all you can hear is your
heartbeat it's been beating since the
moment you were born and you never paid
it any
mind and
now the last thought that pops into your
head right before you hit the
ground I should have listened to it
while I still had the chance because
if I'd listen to that
heartbeat maybe none of this would have
happened I'm sorry what did
happen in this play this woman got
choked with a Rattle and thrown off the
top of the pck lighthouse and our
audience is supposed to think a baby is
my Prime Suspect well yes and no because
what is it Oliver because I don't live
in the
gray Cobo doesn't live in the gray is he
a cobra yeah is he a bro yeah that's how
you gross too Bill not with subtle
subtle un
cell first of all do you see this
Paisley neck cloth I have never been
accused of being subtle and second Ben
Ben rehearsal is a process this is our
first week with this
material when the curtain goes up in 3
months on opening night trust me you're
going to
kill no he definitely died the second
time oh got to
go KT KT KT wait wait okay why are there
people out there striking our sets sorry
Oliver I've got my orders well I'm
ordering you to stop this has to
stop thank you now I'm going to call my
producer and show you that we are all on
the same
page you Deo CEO and founder of Deo
Productions leave your okay well I'll
try the other producer the sun hi it's
Cliff Deo I am also a professional the
reception here is dog they're
pulling the plug Oliver they just don't
want to say it to your
face well then I need to go to them and
she's going with
me Dam it and you can tell those workers
on stage right now that if anyone lays
another finger on my sets I'm going to
wrestle them
too and Oliver putam never Taps
[Music]
out